and we're not even in the first topic
you know better come on tonight
you know three o'clock we get to the
first topic
okay I mean to be fair that the topics
this week we're gonna have a little bit
of fun but they're nothing like serious
discuss yeah yeah there's no FTC stuff
yeah exactly there's a problem before
the storm karma for the storm so next
week we're talking about the FTC most
likely no doubt so games come man what's
going on Xbox got a presence there it's
your topic that and Tokyo game show
they're going to both this year that is
correct that is true and apparently
Tokyo game shows it's gonna be like
their biggest year they've had and so I
don't know if that's like talking about
before the pandemic type of big or you
know it's gonna just be a beefy year for
the Tokyo gangster so
beefy
yeah I'm gonna get a bullhorn and we
walk in a room I'm a yellow beef eh get
out of pocket yo these dude
you so we need a beefy shark your
thoughts on this what do you think as
your topic addict like what do you think
is gonna happen at Gamescom the presence
sex box of Bethesda said they're gonna
be there greedy has put out the Tweet
you know basically stating that um not I
didn't say he didn't say like that
temperature expectations but it was kind
of saying they're looking to show out
you know at the at the at this I love it
I have been a huge
person in the community that's been very
vocal about Microsoft really building
their own outlets and their own events
and not necessarily giving all their
stuff to everyone else and notice they
weren't at the uh they they wasn't at
the Video Game Awards this year they
wasn't at the you know Jeff Keeley thing
whatever that thing was called the
summer game Fest they weren't none of
that stuff and I feel like they could
have easily shown stuff at these events
but they're holding it closer to the
chest is it going to be a huge presence
probably not but we're probably going to
see Game Pass announcements and we're
gonna see some form of maybe you know
exclusive indie games or big type of
games that would be more make more sense
in that type of part of the world I
think we're going to start seeing more
of these little Events maybe uh a direct
to some degree I don't know if it's
going to be anything big but the fact
that they're there and they're showing
their face and these other parts of the
the world because people need to realize
that just because we
enjoy the Xbox brand where in the states
doesn't mean that's the case everywhere
yeah for the most part
they do have some form of an audience in
other parts of the world but it's mainly
just here you know they they get a lot
of their strongest here biggest sells
from this part of the of the world and I
think that's that's the thing they're
doing well you know they've been to
Tokyo game show like two or three years
in a row they're going to Gamescom this
year I I think they're showing like look
we're out in these streets we're we're
showing you what we can do you know we
want to to be better when it comes to
giving better messaging and you know he
came out there he made some uh you know
not necessarily bold statements but some
defining statements and I think that you
know we're gonna see some form of
presence in terms of I don't know if
it's going to be direct or maybe it's
just going to be a couple Tweets in that
day but they're going to be on the show
floor so that's cool but I do think that
we're going to see some form of
announcements that game's gone I I do
think that no doubt no doubt let's get
uh pong soul in the realm Xboxes
presence man they came out there they
said they're going to be you know at a
Gamescom Greenberg with the Tweet
excited to be back this year to see so
many faces familiar and new our teams
have been working hard on our show floor
presence and more this will be
especially yeah looking forward to
sharing even more details soon so upon
what you're feeling what's your thoughts
about this Xbox at Gamestop yeah and it
wasn't just Greenberg either right kaga
it was Phil Phil came out and said it's
been too many years since my last
Gamescom I'm looking forward to
attending and seeing the community at
the show right uh that means something
when the big man's gonna be in the house
that always means something special to
me right obviously I'm you know right in
line with what attic was just saying
um obviously this is also going to be uh
the last week push before Starfield
launches which is one of your biggest
launches you know again arguably in
decades right as far as a first party
game goes so obviously that's probably
going to be a focus like I said it would
be outside of the norm but I wouldn't
doubt to see Starfield maybe playable on
the floor at Gamescom which would be
yeah go against Todd normal you know
what Todd likes to do he doesn't want
anybody seeing his game until launch day
even the reviewers right but I think
it's gonna be different for Starfield so
I I think this could be a big push there
but I definitely think now that we've
got Greenberg out here talking about
this is an exciting special year for
Xbox we already know that Greenie you
guys just came off the gigantic showcase
he came off a direct for Starfield that
blew people's socks out of the water we
know that what what are you saying is it
yeah
I'm double checking to make sure I don't
have my socks on yes
exactly exactly
um so I think that they might have
something special they might have
another thing up their sleeve you know
this goes back to the Giant Bomb
interview with uh Phil and Matt booty as
well uh shout out to grubbing those guys
over there yes
um you know they specifically asked him
about another director what they're kind
of we're gonna do and booty answered
well we've got other things coming up
this year like Gamescom like the Game of
the Year Awards right he specifically
mentioned these shows like attic was
saying I'm in love I I would love the
idea that they have you know three uh
directs a year uh if they've got the
content which they do now to Showcase
but if you're going to use these shows
also as a platform absolutely right this
is something that a lot of us talk about
in the community for a long time the
marketing aspect getting out there and
like addict said to getting to different
parts of the world is always going to be
important for Microsoft and Xbox right
it's always going to be important Europe
is you know they're not they're not
they're doing good but they're not doing
great right and they want to change that
so you got to show up uh to some place
like Gamescom in Germany
um and show what you got and I think we
are we're going to probably get a couple
surprises I think Age of Empires 4 for
console would be a great announcement
here I know everybody says knee genre
but it's still a big game
um and it is due up so age Empire is
four for console and I think they could
have something like a Hi-Fi Rush
um ready to rock and roll or just a
smaller game maybe a couple of smaller
games on the on the horizon maybe some
European devs that they've teamed up
with that we don't know about yet
um yeah exactly exactly no doubt no
doubt pong I like what you're cooking up
Lord finds the readily
Gamescom Xbox is back what do you feel
you know the presence is what are you
expecting from them what would you like
um well given that by the time Gamescom
rolls around we should know about the
whole FTC ruling and everything
um they might have a lot more to show
you know think about it I mean but you
were implying
if that were to happen I mean to show
for it uh not that I don't think they
wouldn't have anything to show for if
they if that deal doesn't go through
because if it doesn't I mean it really
changes nothing for us anyway much we
still get the games whatever we play we
just don't get them in Game Pass but no
I think they have a lot to um offer us
still uh there's still games out there
they they can show more of uh namely
hellblade 2. actual gameplay might be
nice that would be really nice to do
they're gonna have to some combat
they've been working on that combat for
you know we've been hearing about it for
years now
um saying how much better the combat has
gotten we need to see that and I think
that would be a great place to show it I
mean that is the world stage for for
gaming right that is like the massive
World E3 essentially that that's the big
one so show us some gameplay show some
actually
that's what I want to see there with
hellblade too
um uh also I I think that they you know
have other games maybe that um uh were
unannounced so far they'll have an
announcement there maybe not a huge game
but something on the smaller end uh but
exclusive to Xbox
um I'm just I'm not really looking at
this uh Gamescom and thinking we're
gonna see some crazy stuff okay
um from Xbox but I do think that they
can show a lot of good stuff for us and
get us excited still I really do no
doubt no doubt like what you cooking up
dead Lord King where you at man you boys
outside greeny's outside talking about
they're excited you know and continuing
the year of great things to show it
would be mentioned a year specifically
so where you at with Xbox and the big
thinking how has it thought a whole
we're going to be holding the line of
German not us physically but Xbox is
gonna be Hold the Line in Germany
um
first um I I hit young dread in the DM
so we're gonna work
um I have to sign off I have to sign off
yeah I know I know I'm gonna keep you in
a loop on that oh you're gonna keep him
do about my Emojis
you get
them oh okay
okay I've already seen a lot of drawings
on Twitter
make sure you approve those guys
but we got to make sure that this brand
um aren't official yeah yeah yeah say
that there are a lot of talented people
yes yes absolutely young dread is uh
he's calling you up so maybe talent for
these beefy streets this is the
opportunity to uh break because I
usually have a real tight um group that
I work with like graphic god
um
and so maybe
we'll get some new Young Blood up in
there
um about the Showcase her
there's a nothing Burger
they do this every time like they go to
get the games coming they'll be like
yeah Microsoft's gonna be a Gamescom and
they give you all the E3 stuff uh remove
all the fluff uh put uh like whatever
the extra days were consolidate that and
put that on the Reel and throw that up
there and then you know everybody's like
yeah Microsoft had a great show they
might show a couple of Indies and some
deals that they had done now here's the
caveat this is the first time that a big
deal is pending uh of Acquisitions going
into the show right so we feel that by
by the end of next week we should have
some information on the ABK deal be it a
goal be to know right and it's a goal
because I live on positivity time it's a
goal
you might have a change at this little
audible
you know you know Omaha okay
pause
so
um yeah football references
um so I think that might happen and I
think it hinges on that so I'm gonna
give you the scenario that you know if
the APK deal don't go through APK deals
don't go through show be just the same
thing as E3 all that stuff that was
there okay
goes through you will have an extended
welcoming because that's like a coming
out party right that's uh we're here the
other dudes aren't
and you really get the chance to to rub
it in their face because it's just a
little bit different remember the
opposition directly tried to oppose this
so this is where you actually get a
chance to grab their wound open it up
and throw a whole bunch of salt in it
and rub it in on the stage on a national
stage where they aren't there where they
told that demographic that they didn't
matter right so they're going to show
them that this demographic matters and
this deal matters and we're gonna rub it
in your world so real quick question
King if the deal goes through do they
announce the cards and Game Pass at
Gamescom it might happen that same day
they might wait to that day to stand on
stage and say go look at your game pass
now
it's a Call of Duty on oh yeah yeah they
might Diablo might drop
it will be a detrimental day for for a
certain fan base right
and I think and this is this is this is
just a little bit of talk here guys
after this deal goes through we already
know this is acquisition season the rise
of Sith Lord Phil oh [__] Lord and it's
in effect
Tokyo game show oh
wouldn't it be wild to announce where
act we're acquiring Sega we got the
Block is Hot I was thinking that I was
thinking
no the block is not hot the block is not
hot the block is not hot don't ever
think the Block is Hot the deal is good
it's a good deal so they they get the
deal done
what better stage than to because
somebody is floundering in Japan oh man
yep in their backyard right and this is
Sith Lords Phil's finest moment he steps
on that stage and says
we are in talks to acquiring Sega and
comes out on the stage with uh Sega
Chief and this is what we're trying to
do next to take over where they left off
where where the other two the other team
abandoned Japan and I think that sends
everybody in the frenzy and uh little
black man's a soul all over Japan like
it's going out of style I think that's
where they make their Mark you're
looking at Gamescom as the the the the
the the the climax no I think that's the
Catalyst to the climax and the climax is
uh Tokyo uh game show wow you so you
fresh out the court that's right we
right back in and fresh off the federal
investigation yes that's right Teflon
Don Federal Trade and you literally
gonna go make another publisher so write
that in there and keep it pushing yeah
we acquired
and we still had money and you saw the
list guess who's next baby got it come
on
curiosity King
if the deal doesn't go through
no no I I want your honest opinion if
the dough doesn't go through how much of
that money that they were initially
going to give Activision do you think
Microsoft okays for them to reinvest
into other stuff because I I don't think
it's all but I do think it's a good
portion of it would go we can't get
Activision let's look at other things
okay and I'm I'm gonna do it as a Layman
right I'm Gonna Act Like no business no
nothing okay
if I took five hundred dollars and I set
it aside for something and that
something fell through a 500 was gone
anyway so I'm gonna take that 500 and
invest it in other aspects I think every
last dollar of that 70 and and be
forewarned
the deal doesn't go through and it's
blocked by Sony
you have a Target on your heads you have
green you are green lit all right in in
the streets when there's a green light
on you that means y'all saw John Wick
coming out of the corner all over they
would we go get this bounty it's they
will acquire every and anything possible
you want to talk about the stuff that
y'all like to talk about that stuff that
y'all like to do buy exclusive games and
time that out and leave leave a segment
of the community out Microsoft will take
70 billion dollars at erase games from
your platform since y'all like to do
that and FTC think there's nothing wrong
with that well all the games that's
coming out from every third party let's
send some cash they win let's see how it
works and that's organic growth y'all
like that right
it'll be so organic it will organically
fold you up put you in the coffin and I
can't wait to see them do that thing
then in it and ship y'all away yeah my
wrong Ally is gonna be lit if this deal
don't go through y'all just might as
well just sign it up it's over you
better let the deal go y'all better act
for that to happen that's a far less
worse fate than if the deal don't go
through who's doing that little dance
the PlayStation in the casket oh you're
talking about the me when they're doing
the meme
this deal don't go through and boy do
you understand
how do you anger a trillion dollar
company with your billion dollar butt
[Music]
down before I make change oh baby you
don't know that Nino Brown
anyway yo I'm telling you he tried to
play nice this is the rise of Dolph Phil
it's oh it's it's completely over either
way it goes y'all an app anyway bro he
said this is the Vader origin story
right here yo think about it funds
what's Invaders it wasn't wasn't Anakin
such a nice kid oh yeah yeah beautiful
right until they constantly did
different things to upset this man he
has the force he had the ability to
either go left or right and then uh Mace
Windu said yo don't train that dude
because if you give him power he can go
left to right and the anger they angered
this man you did y'all see Phil angry
when he did that interview yeah yeah and
then and that power is that checkbook
is Satya being over there because he's
like
more power
yo I'm telling you and you know why I
knew it was that because when Satay was
on the stand and he said yes
I'm not I don't have any uh stake in
that choice that's young Phil beautiful
if young Phil wants to kill them lets
him die
you know Anakin and he slipped up
because I mean Phil
yeah I mean I see it Darth Vader at the
end is a sympathetic individual that a
lot of circumstances happen to him that
formed him into who he was and he felt
that his decision is right so this is
the rise of the empire y'all have to get
out and lay down these are hours and we
looking for it and you're on the wrong
side of History
um I disagree
um deal with that listen the deal go
through I love King stories though oh
his story is amazing nothing better than
King story listen if the deal go through
he gonna be though
I love y'all I wouldn't know about that
hey I'd be saying next
um if it is but not a flight out yes sir
King acting like like it's like a
restaurant and they bring the steak it's
not cooked enough send it back
I love the movie he watches but oh you
know what it is it's like um
attic and you'll love this is the
restaurant we took you to that Brazilian
restaurant yeah that was yeah I had
nightmares of that place to this day
when you turn that card over and there's
a green light and they keep letting me
come they keep saying this it's it's
like I have a nightmare that like I turn
turn it over to have them stop but it is
green on both sides
he looks over at me
it'll be you know obviously I agree with
you that if the ABK deal the injunction
you know it doesn't you know go through
for the FTC that yeah there's a chance
they call an audible as far as you know
that acquisition and have maybe they
kind of fire up something quick whether
it be an Xbox wire post you know showing
the graphic right
I could see that kind of energy hey
maybe even something from the back of
that team or Game Pass like yo you know
immediately as of da da this is it here
you know kind of like how Bethesda was
as far as like um Gamescom itself it's a
big deal I think it's big when they
actually have a show presence on the
floor when they're on the floor it's a
big deal you set up the booth that's
like that's for the fans yes that's
traditional E3 style this is not like a
online event pass through that means
they're taking Germany and the EU very
seriously and they're spending thousands
of dollars with some people there
absolutely sending people out there
said Phil made the statement you know I
think that's big I think we're also
sleeping on forza's presence I think
Forza has to make a huge dent out there
this is that I didn't like it I didn't
like what they did before right you you
yourself being mad I told I told Maddie
that you said that on defining Duke and
I was like you know King's a big four is
a guy there's a people that want
to the force Affairs defense the
Motorsport got a hardcore the simulation
guy they didn't get the in depth that
they should have necessarily I
personally was fine with their friends
direct but it is a game that's coming
out this year this is the region that is
supposed to put shout out to my man
what's the forza Irwin and um you know
they get it in you know there's a
community that dick like I'm a horizon
guy but the Motorsport guys are a
different breed and that's the graphical
showcasing simulation base because I
didn't get sorry for cutting you off
because it's supposed to be a game of
service right and I didn't get what the
season pass would look like I didn't get
I heard
um the tire thing would change like the
rotation rear mode we don't really know
the details the grit right absolutely I
think we get turn 10 shows up there if I
had to guess and has a nice presence to
really give the you know the car
aficionados what they want and we got to
call you know look God Howard most
likely is going to be outside once they
say Bethesda Xbox and Bethesda there's
the premier title and I don't know about
y'all there's really nothing that
excites me this year Morningstar there's
nothing that you know so you know you
know how it is Starfield we're getting
close and we're getting close yeah two
months away you know they have some form
of a presence there it'll be interesting
to see how much that they divulge
because to add exploit
you know Todd is kind of secretive they
like to do things their way but the
thing I'm noticing now that you're part
of the Xbox game studios you got to
promote this thing this is all hands on
deck from a promotional to build up this
hype train to get this thing going promo
is ready so I expect that to happen
um I'm with you um I forgot who said it
I think it was Fonz about Ninja Theory
um look I'm hoping the UK Studios
presence is strong whether it be
playground games with a little mate
maybe more Fable tidbits and Ninja
Theory especially now
conventional wisdom says Ninja Theory
might not be there only because they
might want to save combat for a
developer direct because they like
already showed it yeah but hey Fox I'm
with you if you want to come out there
and show us another snippet where you
know sending what is actually hey I
won't I won't object because we all
agree that as much as we love Ninja
Theory that showcase showing of it was
it it wasn't it gave it the show any
minuses right because think about this
universe if if selling one hell Blake 2
shows combat and it's phenomenal we're
talk we're elevating that show even the
show was amazing already
it could literally have been the
greatest show of all time for them if
said because we know what Ninja Theory
is telling us to do we kind of know
we're not really scared about what they
got you know what they're gonna do it's
like damn show it show it show it we
need to see that's the last question
kind of thing I I was so disappointed oh
I was yeah addict was
whole point because yeah that was the
slam dunk easily for them but okay I
think they've learned what they need to
do you know saying that I'll see we'll
see we'll see we'll see if they land
we'll see if they learn but that's
pretty much what I got on that and I do
agree that we probably get some Game
Pass deals like I'm with palm completely
on maybe like games you know European
Focus type games with a Game Pass deal
kind of thing and that's pretty much it
but um yeah that's that's what I got on
the uh Gamescom president